[Musik]
Müdigkeitserkennung könte sie w
B
morgen so früh mus K und
hier wenig Schlaf ständig unterwegs das
ist das Leben von sasumar tarmalingam
als hindupriester in der Schweiz ist er
ein viel gefragter
Mann mit einem Gebet schickt er heute
die Seele eines verstorbenen Mannes auf
die Reise ins
Jenseits vor 40 Jahren brach in Sri
Lanka Krieg aus er triebilen in die
Flucht heute leben rund 600
undilen in der
schweiz00 sind pensioniert sie wünschen
sich ein Leben und Sterben in Würde und
nach hinduistischen Traditionen das
steht in Konflikt mit den hiesigen
angeboten und Gesetzen als hindupriester
und Brückenbauer kämpft sasikumar für
die Anlegen der tamilischen
[Musik]
Diaspora
mit 14 flüchtete Sasi Kumar alleine in
die Schweiz seither bestimmt eine Frage
sein Leben wie gelingt der Spagat
zwischen Integration und Bewahrung
integration heißt nicht ihre
identitätsverloren Integration hat heißt
für mich mit dein ander zusammenleber
und wo wir Leber mit dieser Umgebung
anpassen
aber nicht
unsere eigene Identität Kanz
verliere auch der Tod und die Bestattung
sind Teil einer gelungenen
Integration lange mangelte es hier in
der Schweiz an den Voraussetzungen für
traditionell hinduistische Bestattungen
erst vor vier Jahren wurde auf dem
bremmgarten Friedhof Bern der europaweit
erste hindualtar auf einem öffentlichen
Friedhof
errichtetele
gefragt wieso muss ich meine Vater oder
Mutter ihre Sark verbrennen und die
Asche bringen wir irgendwo nach Indien
oder Sri Lanka wir brauchen ein Ort sich
zum wieder erinnern
andingen dann das war eine gute Lösig
auch für die nächste Generation wenn Sie
hier das Abschied fest gemacht hat dann
können Sie auch ab und zu mit diesem
[Musik]
Temp
im Hinduismus werden die Verstorbenen
eingeäschert und im Wasser bestattet so
wird die Seele reing gewaschen diese
Praktik ist für Hindus heilig doch in
der Schweiz praktisch überall
verboten also die Jugendliche nennen
ihre Eltern sind 30 Jahre lang hier
gelebt oder 40 Jahre lang hier
gelebt die wenn er Zürich lebt dann sagt
er der limatplatz ist für mich heilig
oder der wo Basel lebt dann sagt
reheinfluss ist für mir heilig und nicht
dass wir unsere Eltern wo 30 Jahre lang
hier lebe und wir bringen irgendwo eine
unbekannte
Ganges nach eitgenössischer
wasserschutzverordnung ist das beigeben
von Asche eine Verunreinigung der
Gewässer vor drei Monaten reichte
sasiumar beim Kanton B ein
Bewilligungsgesuch ein jetzt heißt es
warten
[Musik]
5 Uhr morgens in Kerz
beibeären Frau und Kind sind meist noch
am schlafen wenn der 48-Jährige
Schweizer das Haus verlässt ob Altar
zwei Fotos geseh ja da Frage genau ist
mein Vater und Mutter
ja mein Vater W de Krieg gestorben und
nach dem Tod von meinem Vater hat meine
Mutter ganz
allein alles
durchgeschafft ja jetzt meine Mutter hat
etwa 10 Jahre lang mit mir
hier in der Schweiz zusammengelebt hat
sie
2013 Abschied
[Musik]
genommen die Vater ist im Krieg
gestorben der kämpft
ne er hat nicht gekämpft aber er ist
vom ruckweg von seiner Arbeitplatz
ähm ja also
mit einer Bombe
ermordet
genau
ja wie auch bist du
gesie damals bin ich
so ja ungefähr S 7 Jahre
alt es ist schwierig wenn ich
darüber rede kommt die ganze Last herus
mm
ja darum ich Fänge nicht viel mit dem
Thema
an Raum für Trauer blieb wenig als
ältester Bruder von drei Schwestern
musste er früh Verantwortung
übernehmen
kindheitserinnerigter gerade eine jetzt
spontan
B ja
also wähend den
W den
kriegzeit ich habe
einfach die Kokosnüsse und die Früchte
wo bei mir zu Hause
wachsen das bringe ich bei ein
Frischmarkt und ich versuche das zum
Verkaufe und mit mit diesem Geld kaufe
ich Reis wenn ich einkaufe dann kommt es
sofort diese erinung wie ich das alles
gemacht wir
[Musik]
genau auch heute kümmert sich der Koch
vor allem um andere tagsüber in seinem
ajurväischen Restaurant danach im Tempel
oder in den Stuben seiner
[Musik]
Landsleute
seine Mutter sah ihren Sohn in Gefahr
und entschied deshalb ihn mit 14 Jahren
alleine auf die Flucht zu
schicken die Frage ist wann sehe ich
wieder die
Familie oder meine
Schwestern und einfach weggehen wo wir
haben nicht geplant also ich habe keinen
Plan dass ich direkt nach Schweiz oder
und meine Mutter hat von meiner Kopf Füß
berühr und gesagt hey ich schließe meine
Liebe Türe ich gebe dir der Schlüssel ab
und ir wenn wir uns sehe dann öffnest du
diese Türe wieder bis dann bleibt mein
Herz wie ein
Stein 12 Jahre musste er warten bis er
seine Mutter Wiedersehen konnte er
strandete in einer Flüchtlingsunterkunft
im Emmental fern ab von allem was er
bishern
für die Schule war er zu alt um zu
arbeiten zu jung wie viele Tamilen fand
er später einen Job in der Gastronomie
und fand so zu seiner Leidenschaft dem
Kochen heute ist das Haus der Religionen
in Bären sasikumars
Lebensmittelpunkt hier führt er sein
Restaurant wakam gleich daneben steht
der Hindutempel den er mit Freunden ins
Leben gerufen hat sie störten sich daran
dass nach alter hinduistischer Tradition
nur Männer aus der richtigen Kaste das
Priesteramt ausüben dürfen nach dem
Studium der heiligen Schriften und der
Konsultation ihres Gurus in Indien
fassten sie den mutigen Entschluss ihren
eigenen reformtempel zu gründen hier
gilt das traditionelle Kastensystem
nicht das Priesteramt steht allen Frauen
und Männern offen und die Gebete werden
nicht in Sanskrit sondern auf Tamilisch
gesprochen
s ja der Weg zur Reformation ist das
einfach weg schwieriger
Weg ja wie reagiert mit auf die Idee
oder ja es war ein sehr schwieriger Weg
auch wir haben sehr viel Kritik erlebt
von
weltweit ja manchmal ist auch
Lebensgefahr kann man sagen ja wenn ich
das im Sri Lanka Indien vorstelle noch
schwieriger aber hier auch in im Europa
ist nicht so ganz einfach
sie ganz am Anfang sehr schwierig aber
jetzt wir gewinnen sehr viele nächste
zweite
Generation wo sie
diese Reformation akzeptiert und
siebt heute bereiten er und sein Team
eine Hochzeit für 600 Gäste
vor was geht ja das ist wir glauben got
ist nicht nur Form sondern hat er auch
formloses aber diese
formlosesormes Energie wir geben eine
Darstellung rundum mit dem Schnur das
ist unsere 72000 Nervensystem der
kokosmus ist so wie unser Kopf diese
fünf Manko Blätter sind unsere Auge Nase
Ohren so die fünf Sinne und das ist eine
Präsenz von diese Kosmo dass sie mit den
Anwesen von diesem alle Heiligen sie
schwören dass sie miteinander zusammen
die
e schlüßung
stattfindet die Ehe hat in der
tamilischen Kultur einen hohen
Stellenwert traditionell bestimmen die
Eltern unter Berücksichtigung der
Kastenzugehörigkeit wer wen
heiratet die junge Generation die hier
aufgewachsen ist fordert mehr
Selbstbestimmung der reformtempel zieht
Heiratswillige aus der ganzen Schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an
nein ich muss noch oben kurz parkierere
ich muss die Asche
holen
Verg aber we ich jetzt das
fürasche was bringt
fürasche ne das ist die heilige W
man wenn ich sie besuche dann gebe ich
sie als ein Segen ah nicht der Asche vor
Mens die erste flüchtlingsgeneration
bestand vor allem aus tamilischen
Männeren sie gingen von einem kurzen
Krieg und einen raschen Rückkehr aus
darum blieben sie in der Schweiz oft
unter
sich jetzt 40 Jahr später wie geht's den
Menschen der erste Generation ja ja also
ich sehe da viele die sterben sehr früh
weil
wenn ich höre 65 67 sie haben schon
viele Krankheiten ja und die Ursache
wenn ich suche
das ist ein schlecht
ernährt oder eine grenzlose Arbeitszeit
ja sie haben sehr sehr viel anstrengende
Arbeit gemacht und damals haben sie
Beispiel bis 10 Jahre lang hab haben sie
keine Bewilligung wo aus der
schweizerische Grenze zu gehen viele
sind auch
Alkoholiker weil sie sind ganz allein
keine andere Beschäftigung
Heimweh und z.B einer wo verheiratet
hatte drei Kinder zweijährig dreijährig
vierjährig und dann hat er diese Familie
bis in der Schweiz zu bringen müsste
noch 15 Jahr warte wegen den Bewilligung
und nach 15 Jahren wenn er se seine Frau
und Kinder die Kinder haben fast
keine Verbindung mit der Vater oder das
sind alles nicht weggeschafft also hier
hat man keine Therapie gekriegt oder
irgendeine unterstützung hatten sie
nicht und das sind alles die Ursache wo
auch manchmal ich sehe einige Familie wo
Männer sehr
alkoholiger
Gewalt ist ist alles da
aber wen ich
ihre hintergrü warum mein so
etwas dann möchten wir gerne
unterstützen heute leben in der Schweiz
über 10000 passensionierte tamilinnen
und Tamilen traditionell kümmern sich in
Sri Lanka die Kinder um ihre Eltern die
Realität in der Schweiz sieht oft anders
aus darum hfen sich für sasumar Besuche
in
Altersheimen
Frau ist 74 1991 kam sie als Witwe mit
zwei Töchtern in die
schweizmer nehmen Sie den Teppich unter
die
Füße das ist lieb
danke wie geht
alterim es ist schwierig das einzige was
mir gut gefällt ist dass ich immer einen
Arzt rufen kann ja aber sonst vermisse
das tamilische Essen vermisse die
Sprache wenn ich mit anderen tamilienen
zusammen wäre könnten wir schöne
Erinnerungen austauschen hier habe ich
keine
Freunde ihr größte Schmerz der Verlust
ihres Sohnes mit 21 ist er im Krieg
gefallen das Schicksal von Frau saroni
teilen viele tamilische Eltern um ihr
Leid zu Ländern und ihnen ein altern mit
Würde zu ermöglichen planen sasikuma und
seine Leute ein wohnhheim für tamilinnen
und
Tamilen ெஞ்சில் ினைக்கும்
உத்தమருదమக்கరங்கி அழகு வலி வெற்றி தనం
தన్யம் ோయిின்மை தொகை தரும் ப பேரும்
தந்தருள்வாய் மதுரை
[Musik]
பராபரமே
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im Tempel gibt es heute Anlass zum
feieren das Bewilligungsgesuch für
wasserbestattungen wurde angenommen das
Recht auf eine schickliche Bestattung
sei in diesem Fall höher zu gewichten
als das
[Musik]
wasserschutzgesetz eren heute Menschen
die sie auf diesem Weg unterstützt
[Musik]
haben gesetzliche Grundlage beruh
Gesellschaft wie sie n ist Sache gerade
im Berich
Religion ke
einzig einzige geszliche Grundlage was
auf andere religionsginchaft bezieht und
jetzt nichtuchen sondern von bürgerinen
Bürger
hier Aufwachen die 25 jah
hier ein Abend zu Hause mit seiner
Familie eher selten seit 23 Jahren ist
sasikuma mit seiner Ehefrau sangeta
verheiratet ihre Tochter ist 21 der Sohn
18 Jahre alt
was ist
das mein Bruder hatte so viel so schöne
Sachen erzählt von Sassi für mich war
eine held in meiner Jugend es war schon
Anfang an
eine gewünschte Hochzeit oder wie sagt
man also von euch gewünscht oder von den
Eltern oder so gewünscht von all Seite
Tochter samjukta arbeitet als
Kleinkinderzieherin Sohn hariram macht
die Ausbildung zum
Naturheilpraktiker wie viele tamilische
Kinder in der Schweiz haben sie nbst der
Grundschule am Wochenende die tamilische
sprach und kulturschule
besucht Vater ist mit
der mit
ist
Generation lieber mit der
H besser
aber
immer
besser
ihr Partner war F komplett frei was
Kultur Religion abelangt oder wie ist
das be
euch für mich ich find schonilis
ja einfach D mit dem Kultur dass ich mir
viel woher fühl oder
und ja deswegen ja W ich eigentlich sch
frei überl vom Erz
her für mir selber ist so wichtig dass
zukünftige Partner tam ist W ich einfach
gern die gich Werte und Normen
Pflege dass
man mal tampo geht dass man dir Witze
versteht oder aber gich Sicht hat auf
Kultur denke einfach ja dan mit de woh
als Eltern haben wir auch eine Erwartung
dass wir ein mitsprech recht hat
und sicher es gibt auch Diskussionen
aber der was noch der Vordergrund steht
die bedürfn Bedürfnisse von Kinder ihre
Erwartungen sind auch für mich sehr
wichtig auf all meine Fragen hat Antwort
bereit unerklärt bleibt für mich wie er
mit seinem Mammutprogramm und so wenn
ich schlaf zurecht kommt also wie
schafft das mit so wenig
schlaf ich eigentlich auch nicht er
kommt eigentlich relativ
spät
früh Frage mir W schafft also könt
nicht richtig ja ich sehe auch das ist
wichtig für mein Gesundheit dass ich
achten müsste und die Kinder haben immer
Druck gegben ich muss
unbedingt Schlaf ja ich
versuche ja
ja und dann ruft die Pflicht zur späten
Stunde rückt der Vater nochmals aus
ein 80-jähriger Tamile liegt in
kritischem Zustand im
Spital dass der Seelsorger auch
außerhalb der Besuchszeiten Eintritt in
schweizerheime oder spitäller erhält war
lange nicht selbstverständlich jem hat
kzkrankheit sie wird er wird bald
sterben und seine Töchter möchte dass
ich unbedingt da bei haben und ich er
möchte diese spirit Lieder hören und
dann bin ich gekommen so 1 Uhr
und damals sie kennen uns nicht und ich
habe keine Badge oder irgendeinen
Beweismittel nur Ausweis oder sie haben
einfach gesagt der besuchzeit ist er
wieder morgen ja das geht einfach nicht
so ich bin ein hind seellsorger und ich
habe mit Patient Gebäude n
23 danke vi dank die Zusammensetzung der
Schweizer Bevölkerung hat sich verändert
und damit auch die Nachfrage nach
Seelsorgenden 2018 boti Universität Bern
erstmals einen Studiengang für religiöse
Begleitung im migrationskontext an zu
den ersten diplomierten gehörte auch
sasumar vor 20
Jahre vorstellen dass ich ein
Spitalbesuch machen könnte ich auch kein
Mut ja also kein vertrauen
dürfen wir überhaupt so etas verlangen
weil für für uns das ist auch sehr neu
äh jetzt aktuell
wir merken das ist wichtig dass man ein
professionelle selbsorg geben sollen und
es ist auch sehr notwendig im Spital
wenn jemand in äh not Situation da ist
für sie mit den kleicher Sprache und
ihre Gefühle einfach direkt zum
Ausdrucken ist ist sehr
wichtig solche Besuche leistete er
früher ehrenamtlich heute werden er und
andere nichtchristliche seelsorgende
dafür
bezahlt
[Musik]
im Haus der Religionen findet heute ein
Gedenktag statt an die 40jährige
Fluchtgeschichte der tamilischen
Bevölkerung organisiert hat ih die junge
Generation die damit zeigen möchte dass
sie das Schicksal der
flüchtlingsgeneration nicht gessen
[Musik]
hat hat Event
mitorganisiert wie s engagiert sie sich
in der tamilischen Diaspora als
Mediatorin und interkulturelle
Vermittlerin dieses Bild hier gefällt
mir am
besten haben es für den fer
genommen
Generation ne s w ne und das wir
Generation
unf nur zumat wo oder er muss er muss
sparsam mit
rource so wie die erste Generation am
Schluss einfach nur noch keine Kraft
mehr
s ja genau also
Streit her aber ist das wie das z B das
nicht nicht abgrenz ist
wieilis und und n Schwizer Wert abgrenz
oder so oder ja mit
Jugendzentrum gar nicht
vorstellen da ganz we und richtig Wasser
geschossen
Word unterschiedlich
Anfangspunkt meine Konflikt Z
generationpren die die gröte
Konflikt them
Land
ich B schon mal mit de
[Musik]
Thema Tabu Thema Gesellschaft aber d
schon persönlich interkulturelle
vermitt
homosexuell da bin zum fragt du bist so
offen WST du e homosexuell
TR nein aktu
stand ja das die Frage Generation betff
betff ja da brauche ich ein bisschen
Zeit du wie mit
Reformation n
dasystem aber jetzt kann ich kritisch
sage ja du die Homosexuellen nicht die
gich recht das ist ja System s nicht so
vieler ja also die menschliche Werte ich
setze sehr also jeder Mensch hat auf
dieser Erde hat ein recht wie er äh für
ihm richtig ist leben möchte und von der
religiö Sicht her auch wir nehmen den
Menschen äh an wie sie sind wir also ich
bin bereit das zum akzeptieren aber
warum h nicht die gleiche Recht also
wenn du wenn du mich fragt ob ich diese
Ritual führe da bin ich noch nicht
bereit also es braucht vielleicht
wirklich Zeit mit dieser Reformation
aber am Moment ich bin nicht bereit se
ein Ritual zu führen
die 33jährige Bernerin war als Kind oft
mit ihren Eltern im Tempel die Räume
sind für sie eine Art zweite
[Musik]
Heimat Druck von der erste Generation Z
hey
bewahre mit Hochzeit und so du mus
mus
kungs wenig kontr
fr sozial Gesellschaft Kontrol und das
versuch
ich sch ma
jof die junge
frauarbeit die
Fam platert Word Gang und mit
den
mit
Zech
aber
das Brückenbau zwischen der tamilischen
und schweizerischen Kultur verdankt sie
mit unter
senheitration er se nicht so ist es
sondern er es ist so weil es ist so weil
Erk und off für neue
Argumente das schätz
enorm nicht da und W nicht so fr machen
muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen dann ist es soweit im dezember
2023 kann die erste offizielle
wasserbestattung durchfüren
[Musik]
das kantonale Amt für Wasser und Abfälle
hat große Zugeständnisse gemacht nbst
der Asche dürfen ein Teelöffel Milch und
einzelne Rosenblätter in dieare gegeben
werden und maximal 20 Waser
damit ist klar fürar ist dieutige
Bestattung eine genugung aber sein
Einsatz geht weiter damitilinen undilen
in der Schweiz würdeevoll leben alten
und sterben
[Musik]
können னோடு நேசம் காமதேவன் நாசம்